both sides are now in damage control
mode after amber heard's grueling
testimony at her and johnny depp's 50
million defamation trial welcome to
entertainment tonight michelle turner
has the night off amber capped off her
second day on the stand telling the jury
that johnny made her fear for her life
[Music]
he got next to my ear and he was
screaming over and over and over again i
hate you i
hate you and then
pounding the back of my head
pounding it with his fist
it just hit me over and over and over
again and i got really still i thought
this is how i die
he's gonna kill me now
johnny spokesperson calls the actress
testimony the performance of her life
team amber fired back saying depp's
behavior is pitiful he doesn't have the
courage to look at her and instead he
doodles and snickers
and there was this incredibly tense
moment in court amber steps down from
the stand yesterday as johnny walks to
the exit you can see amber's stunned
look as he gets close a bailiff keeps
the actor back and amber is escorted
from the courtroom
fascination with the trial continues as
rumors have quickly spread on social
media that the actress had lifted a
portion of her testimony where she
talked about her relationship with
johnny from this scene in the talented
mr ripley when you have his attention
you feel like you're the only person in
the world when i was around johnny i
felt like the most beautiful person in
the whole world
we fact checked and found just two
slightly similar moments it felt like
a warm glow
it's like the sun shines on you johnny
who denies amber's claim of domestic
abuse is claiming defamation ensuing
heard for 50 million
she's filed a countersuit for 100
million
amber also testified about appearing on
the late late show with james corden one
day after that alleged fight in 2015. i
had my hair and makeup team come and
they worked around the bruising by
covering it i told people i had an
accident
so lauren here's the good news both
johnny and amber will have reprieve from
all this drama oh and all of us too yes
yes trial resumes on may 16.